[Music]
[Applause]
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and interesting topics
but then there is one subject that we
somehow missed
welcome home my tuber friends every home
is different and love is central to
every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings
hey how's it going bros today
we're playing the scariest game
of all time
slenderman he's a slendy mandy
slenderman you are champion
slenderman sunderman i learned a new
song
we summon slenderman with this song
[Music]
slender if you're real kidnap me i'm a
child
[Applause]
too scary we have to do it guys everyone
grab your recorder and let's do this
together
yeah yeah put your browser on dark mode
right now because it's about to get real
slenderman if you're there we're
summoning thee
all right first i want to react to my
old slender video
the classic here's me as you can see i'm
using obs
and my microphone is peaking i should
probably do something about that
eh ain't got time all right so this is
in 2012 dude
god damn 13 million views that is
actually not that much
right i thought slender was bigger than
that what the [ __ ]
i guess in 2012 youtube wasn't as big
this was like the first viral
kind of thing i had which was that i
found this game called slender
on my bro army.net forum
someone posted it i double checked on
youtube has anyone else played this
nothing no one and i was like this is
gonna be amazing
i i thought to myself i better pull out
my craziest face
for the face can
there's a thing i did i thought it was
funny to start off the
the video with a crazy face because you
only see it for a second if you really
look
how's it going bro god damn i look
different hey
can i see this can i compare oh no what
happened
i used to be blind now i'm just right
now i'm just
death at least i'm stronger now i could
kick the [ __ ] out of that
okay at least i got that on him i
remember that shirt
my mom gave me that shirt
welcome to i guess the game will show
you in
there it is slander it is an
um horror game it seems pretty basic
i think it was made for a competition or
i'm mixing it up with something else
it wasn't made for a competition i don't
think so at least maybe i'm mixing it up
with something else
how scared did i get oh
[Laughter]
laughing at myself eight years later
hey i hit that ten minute mark i don't
think that was intentional yeah yeah
this is my first viral
hit i was so proud because i always
wanted it
okay enough of that i just wanted i just
wanted to see it before i play it
let's load this bad boy up are you guys
ready yeah
spoopy first let me just do this
i'll see
[Applause]
i don't remember that this is annoying
stop it
you ruined my intro how's it going bros
my name is beautypack
welcome to a new game i found it's
called
slender i think it's the first game
or the second uh i don't know i could be
confusing it with something else
but it should be pretty scary
all right slander
eight pages ah
brows this is crazy collect
eight pages oh god it's so dark
oh no follow me bros
we'll get the eight pages i've never
actually beaten the game
i don't think i can it's really
difficult but i'm up for the challenge
bros
okay eight pages let's go ah we found
the first one
brush it's right here what does it say
let's check it out brush
[Music]
stephano stefano are you what there
i need your help man eight pages
it's just seven more god damn i'm slow
oh the truck the there's the red truck
and then there's the blue truck
i remember this there's a red and blue
truck inside the man of course
of course i'm a gamer i knew this
but where's the note bros is it not on
the truck
i swear to god doesn't it is it not is
there seriously no note on it
all right no luck bros
god i run out of breath quick huh all
right we must we must be strong brush
the barrels are coming for us those
[ __ ] barrels
no it's god am i walking in circles
well we'll know soon enough
that blue truck just as i remembered it
bros
there must surely be a note on this the
blue truck
if it's not on the red truck it's on the
honestly it's got to be here right
what yeah yeah yeah i found that funny
follows ross what do you think is
following us
two pages yes six more let's go
okay but where bruhs
do something it's fine i probably should
stop running so much
jennifer give me this
there's no jennifer's in this game i
think we shook him brows
all right it's deeper in the woods just
don't look back
god damn it we need six more pages are
you serious
this can't be happening bros oh
god i remember this bros
maybe stefano is in there or maybe
teleported naked guys
oh oh
should we look back oh he's not behind
us okay good
mr chair mr jam what are you doing mr
jack
mr chair who puts tiles on the floor
what yeah mr chair
felix i'm sorry i couldn't find a note
god damn i'm disappointed in you mr
chair i will not be chairman
activating any longer okay that's all
right
isn't that you usually like
scoop
i need you man i can't do this without
you man
oh god oh
he's teleporting
stop i'm going to the woods brush
it's our only chance to make it we got
gotta do this bros
we got two pages we can do this
i got a good feeling all right
here we go he can't catch him he's slow
he may be able to teleport but he
doesn't have like i don't have legs damn
it
this is a problem we're not gonna die at
two pages this is embarrassing i'm older
i'm smarter i'm fast this is the start
stop you can't catch me slendy i'm not a
child i'm a man now
i ain't afraid look i'll play without
the lights on
slender's just teleported naked guys but
without the naked part it all makes
sense
oh come on man i'm so s i didn't realize
just how
slow you are like you're barely moving
another fence i found the blue truck
i found the red truck oh that's not good
is he over there that means he's over
there
[ __ ] what you can't just do that and
silent i haven't even found any note yet
it's all good it's all good
dude i am actually no i'm not scared
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember these
the silos
of course brush the silo
the cybros as i like to call them
okay it's on one of these we just got to
find it
it's got to be on that side
okay okay i'm going for it i'm going for
it i'm going for it i'm going for it
[Applause]
i gotta go where he is this is total
bullcrap all right he's gone he's gone
i'm not afraid uh where are the [ __ ]
notes
i'm starting to think there are no notes
in this goddamn game it's too dark i
can't i can't see [ __ ]
no no
no fine i don't care anymore
i can't find a single note
i've actually devolved over the mistake
yeah
why why what
this no
stop i know we can't be outside the
building but i scanned it
oh what the [ __ ] dude what'd i do
what'd i do i didn't do nothing
oh [ __ ] ah
bros i think this is it not even stefano
can get
oh the flashlight does run out you were
right oh no
you were oh no you were correct
and i was wrong it's fine
as long as i keep moving it will be okay
what is this is this my last hope
yes i found one i got it
yes oh i remember now there's another
place to go
let's go i'm a gamer three pages let's
go browse
hell yeah we can make we can make it
stop riding f
we can make it i hate woods i've always
hated woods
super sweden they always freaked me out
the moment he's not behind me don't
worry he's not behind me
oh i was right okay cool
stop no i'm trying so bad to see
man yes yes we're gonna get another one
no [ __ ] way i'm dying on three
the cylinder of course oh god i'm so
slow
okay yeah i got you man
where's the note there's there's
no notes he took them all down i knew it
i [ __ ] knew it
without me three out of eight
oh god that was terrible i think that
was the problem i had too much grass
detail
uh this is better those goddamn bearings
must be working with slenderman
how do they know should i say my
flashlight yeah yeah good call good call
i can't tell if the map is really huge
or if i'm extremely snuck
okay that's that's the tree there's
always a note on the tree
that's not a tree well we got ourself a
new voice
and gauss of course yeah help me i'm not
helping you jennifer
it did i love it shut up
i hate you stupid jennifer
i'm married now jennifer get over it i
can't see anything
uh yes bros it's that
thing there's always one on these
oh there's always guaranteed 100 percent
100 spawn rate i told you bros
i told you no no no no what about yes
yes
yes yes two notes let's go brush
bros i must save my batteries chopped
knees
i speak japanese yeah
i feel like there's something stuck in
my
butt uh much quack like what the
quackity bag was that it i don't
care hey that's happy wheels we'll play
that at some point
[Music]
i don't love
what's that myself was that what game
was that dead space
i guess uh three pages is my limit huh
police bill was a reference
dude someone left the toy truck of toy
police car at my old flight in sweden
one time and i was so confused no slime
oh i got dodge time
we found the blue truck yes mouse
we're on three yeah
now onwards to that red truck
i gotta make it to four bro and not yet
now yeah
come at me bro come at me bro
the red truck we found it
please please please please
please please yes
four the red drug
ain't no putting like a pewdiepie party
bonfire checkpoints in disguise
hey pewter do you think i'm sexy pewds
yeah yeah i'm picky yeah
oh this that silo yes
could we be the fifth page this is it
thanks for sticking with my channel ever
since that was a note
yes bye baby let's go
oh god no what have i done
there's three more we can do this
i am so lost
my face is so scarier than the game oh
there's t-mode
what is that what the what i've never
seen that before
is that a glitch oh it's the wall it's a
wall feeling stinks
great all right all right all right we
got this we got this
six baby six baby i'm coming for you six
baby six have i looked at this before i
i don't remember
ah frick
no not like this rose
oh god
i can't do that voice anymore i ruined
my vocal cords over the years of
screaming
come on there's gotta be one here i can
smell it
i'm triangulating sonar this [ __ ]
that's how the speedrun pros does it all
right i'm starting to think maybe there
isn't a note on this one
they call it
[Music]
no not the blue truck
i made it i made it i made it
yeah i'm gonna run out of batteries any
second
f's in the chat
five new record hey i'll take it very
nice
i think i'm slendered out but i enjoy
that hope you guys did as well
very nice it was megan fox
after all these years she came back
forgot how draining it is to play horror
games
i mean i'm not like i was scared or
anything
oh good i'm trying to turn on my lights
there we go
ah
ah yes sprouse that was crazy
now smash like and subscribe
for more epic yeah hope you guys enjoyed
smash
like subscribe look at graph and
uh yeah see ya profit
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing
it's beautiful now as a popular demand
this thing now works with pc games top
pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom gotta try
this baby on doom
pubg valeran you name it
okay we don't have every game but a ton
of games so the blaster now works with
geforce now which is very cool
it also works with pc it has a ton of
library of android games
it's just a new way to play we're
bringing it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get ten dollars
off if you enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out